ladies and gentlemen we have made it to
the finale of cobra kai season four
andrew has joined us on this hell of a
long journey it's the log one so he's
got a notepad today
every last easter egg andrew weak mind
can't remember remember i forgot the
moment of truth last episode in survivor
and uh the red geese even though i
pointed it out didn't remember to say it
in the easter eggs it doesn't matter
what you pointed out what matters what
you didn't point out
you made an ass out of both of us yeah
that's what you're defining the true
cobra kai guys leave a like if you think
andrew messed up and if you don't think
he messed up leave a like subscribe and
click that notification bell to get
accepted into the reject nation hey full
leg watch launch receive with the time
code for coping car over at our patreon
page cover a bunch of shows over there
as well thank you to all the become
superjects and of course thank you to
the boys over at prepper for helping us
edit down these highlights let's get
into action people
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
do you know where you are
can you tell me your name richard jewell
call that detective tell ms jondo is
awake john do huh
good news
looks like it's just a pulled muscle
let the pain guide you if it's telling
you to sit this one out i'd listen i'll
get you an ice pack thank you
get back in there you
whimpy alexa battle it out
i feel like a helpless jedi youngling
about to get slaughtered okay well
you're taller you have the high ground
and so obi wan won't be anakin right
breathe in breathe out breathe through
you got this come on
come on dimitri lee score a point
[Applause]
damn robbie's so in control
[Music]
no point try to make them like one word
notes
damn what matters what you didn't point
out
[Music]
[Applause]
i guess he didn't have the high ground
i'm sorry okay for all the
for all the [ __ ] i did and you know it
wasn't
cool and i guess i was just trying to
impress your friends by picking on the
new kid who didn't have any
i could i can i can imagine what it must
have felt like you can imagine that you
wouldn't know
because no one's ever been such a piece
of [ __ ] to you
well maybe it's time you found out
whoa oh [ __ ] get ready for high school
next year cause you're gonna be in the
world
good last name
this is not how i trained you
it's cobra kai
no mercy you lost him in that fight bruh
anthony just just said leave me alone
way to go robbie
you made a monster
now we know how obi-wan felt with anakin
you were the chosen one damn
it was gonna be a battle for the agent
didn't have to be this way johnny it
could have been with me and your real
son
oh if i can help robbie win
he'll remember it for the rest of his
life
and maybe someday
he can be the one to keep cobra guy
going
well that's never gonna happen
cobra kai never dies but season five
what do we call the show dude i want to
go out there miguel do what i tell you
we'll not only take down cobra kai we'll
show larusso and everybody else who's
really the best that's what this is
about hey we're not gonna get another
shot at this miguel diaz has one minute
to return to the mat
lethal weapon had a countdown clock at
one point ah it's easter
it's a good one it looks like miguel
diaz is not going to fight
the winner by default is eli moskowitz
where he will face
robbie king holy [ __ ] damn
it just felt like i wasn't fighting for
me anymore
hmm i get that i feel pressure from my
dad all the time yeah accepted johnny
isn't my dad
i gotta go
but i'll see how they're eating for me
right
i'm always rooting for you sam
oh
you made the right choice miguel
yeah you made that backwards also yeah
all right it's like that's so smart to
go out there
spiderman tell people where's back i
know
yankee don't wins both matches the title
is dead
good luck to all of our fighters
let's go
mike barnes special referee nope guess
not you find your balance and those
points will come
right predators must not lose to fear
[Music]
he traded miyagi way longer than me
and you
weren't cobra kai longer than him you
each know each other's karate better
than anyone put him on defense
they fought in season one in the
tournament i forgot
[Music]
that should be like four points
nice
oh
[Applause]
damn i'm so stressed out right now
oh
damn the choreography is it's a tie yeah
i know their championship match will be
decided for the first time since 1985
mike barnes
just like mike barnes and daniel let's
get mike barnes in here yeah special
referee
[Music]
why don't you fix your shirt
you've had time
that was incredible
is the advice of the last point
sweep the legs
you have a problem with that
[Music]
take it off
well
show the hawk
damn robbie
[Music]
damn you like
yeah buddy all right guys pick up our
shirts let's do it
fight all the way naked
wow
wow dude oh wow
wow
oh yes
wow
a shot
[Music]
i like pins and needles whoa
come on
yeah that's great that was awesome
second place again for robbie
[Applause]
it all comes down to the girls fighter
oh no damn i thought he was going to do
the jon claude van damme splits kick him
in the nuts
you can pay me back now
um by making sure sam doesn't get hurt
what
i'm not asking you to back down i just
want you to play by the rules don't hold
back tory my money's on sam
oh what if sam plays dirty what do you
want
i want your help
because i cared so much about honoring
mr miyagi's legacy but i forgot one of
his most important lessons
just like one side
choose a way grow because the root is
strong
you choose one way to color the same
reason
yeah but i do it your way
one day you do one
some of what you teach
can be good sometimes
and i'm sorry i didn't realize that
[Music]
i'm sorry too
i saw you and miguel bonding and i
freaked out
well since it seems the water is flowing
back under the bridge
what do you say we team up again
you want me to help me agile win
miyagi
[Music]
we set that earlier in the season
this show's breaking my heart man and
all the right ways
without breaks
yes
uh some move right now the queen cobra
herself
tory nichols
i think any season's got him you're so
emotional
[Applause]
daniel russo who will be joined by
sensei johnny lawrence
he's like what
two-time all valley champion sensei and
john and lauren
you
[ __ ]
i want you to win more than anyone
whether it's defense
or offense biagido or ego fang i want
you to be you oh just make sure you keep
your anger in check
i
was not ready for this what is happening
right now
she's good
go kick some roads yeah
bye
oh boy
[Music]
ah
she's fighting aggressive then you get
more aggressive
i've seen what's inside you let it out
there's a lot of time that's in this
tournament that holland zimmer composed
the scorpions
zimmer and james newton howard cut the
batman begins dark knight team
dude the chun li kick oh sam hold it
together i'm attacking but it's not
working what style should i use
yours
trust your instincts
sure so cool
she went out after she got hit
[Music]
fixed refereeing terry paid him off
ready
come on
time to do some cocaine
elbow to the face
go to your senseis
i didn't need you
no it was an accident go to your senseis
this ref is really on tory's side that
sucks she comes in like that again give
her a shot to the other eye i don't need
to cheat to win second place is no place
you're off
you're nothing you're lost you're a
loser suck yeah
oh my god crease is having a reflective
moment boy let him go
who's the loser i don't hear you
i don't remember that dialogue you've
come this far
this is your fight now
they actually like frank dukes with the
dust in the face bloodsport
this music is so good
[Music]
[Music]
nice
[Music]
[Applause]
didn't give her that point
[Applause]
and the ref should have got the trophy
we did the right thing
and we still didn't win
i'm sorry
it's not your fault it's the ref spot
sam
hey victory party at my place queen
cooper you gonna be coming to what yeah
i just got to grab my bag from the
locker room all right cool hey guys
let's go let's go i'm just gonna have a
heart-to-heart with samantha played it
just right
no one suspects a thing
i called that
the mvp andrew yes
kenny i thought i could take him under
my wing
be the mentor i wish i had when i was
younger but when i saw him today it uh
it's like looking at him here
and i had all this hate inside of me
for you and for miguel
but it just made things worse and and
now it's never gonna get better that's
not true
you had a good thing going with a russo
i got in the way that don't blame
yourself you blame me oh
i'm sick of blaming you dad
calm dad
what sucking miguel came and saw this
everyone has a weakness john and mine is
you it's you i have been your strength
ever since vietnam yes
there it is how many times do you expect
me to repay that debt before we swear
what
what did you do
it's okay raymond the man who did this
can't hurt you oh jesus christ
give me his name and i promise you i'll
put him away for a long long time i'll
make you cobra guy
but you got to do something for me oh oh
wow his name is sensei crease
crease
damn oh wow huh that's a good way to
prepare terry the snake
john crease you're under arrest for
aggravated assault and attempted murder
you have the right to remain silent what
did you do it's behind your back
yes
yes put him in the car and don't worry
about lawrence
i'll take good care of him too
oh boy damn
oh you are evil man
old terry silver
[Music]
man he's wearing the toby maguire suit
from spider-man 3 just saying the way
they've zigzagged terry in and out of
this season what's going on
show him the no oh
he ran away
i'm still not sure who i want to be
to figure that out i think i need to
know where i came from wow
instead of competing for a trophy
i need to meet my father
this is something i have to do
there's something i didn't tell you
about my ex-husband he doesn't know
miguel exists
if cobra kai is going to keep growing
and getting stronger i need to do
whatever it takes to stop them i know
this isn't your fight and this is a lot
to ask but will you help me finally put
an end to cobra guy chosen
yes
you add to your collection
oh i'm so excited
now terry's got to get mike barnes yeah
they got to call hillary swank now
damn
wow
all right season five let's go
wow
it's official another season is coming
all right john kick us off i thought
this was a very emotionally potent and
resonant finale and uh yeah there's
definitely
gonna be a season five uh i'm almost at
a loss for where to begin but i guess we
gotta begin with miguel
uh because so much hinged on the sort of
bookends of his journey and you know so
much of the show has been about him and
johnny up until this point and uh yeah
like that that first domino of his
choice to leave the tournament and to
you know really choose what's best for
himself
even though while that's happening a lot
in the background of the episode i
thought that was you know a really kind
of heavy and potent setup for you know
where his journey is is to go uh next
but yeah just all the different
emotional
payoffs like i didn't expect to cry so
much throughout this episode and uh yeah
just
watching the different you know
approaches that these senseis take in
order to secure you know this victory
that is going to decide the entire fate
of who's going to get to teach and
whatnot
and i thought they did a really nice job
of luring you into focusing just on you
know the tournament at hand
and then throwing a whole bunch of other
twists and curves that you know you knew
that there was going to be set up
uh but i didn't expect you know half the
things especially with you know terry
silver and crease and all that and yeah
miguel leaving so uh
you know that's sort of the first stuff
that uh came to my mind and of course
like the fights i thought were really
really
tense
and uh well choreographed well shot to
just you know even though you know
not even the outcomes but just you know
we've been to the tournament before
throughout this series and i thought
they managed in season four to still
make it as thrilling and you know pulse
pounding as possible while also meeting
that emotional resonance so uh yeah yeah
it's very true i think
i think what they did with the
tournament in particular is they
it
whereas a lot of you know i usually
tournament and especially like in the
karate kid trilogy
what's called the fourth one this is the
first season to end without setting up a
returning character uh from like
like i think a lot of people were
expecting it like uh hilary swink or
something to be teased right i think a
lot of people probably feel like mike
barnes was teased though which i'm going
to mention here later
i think you just did that yeah
well i mean when terry sorry yeah it's
already silver saying we're going to get
a guy or two in here to help out but
yeah sorry
normally it's like pretty overversed
yeah no no that's true that's that's
true yeah
i think uh
um well i was saying that i think what
this tournament did
as opposed to like victory
or just relishing and that is if
anything what it did was reveal
everything that was really going on
underneath everyone during this whole
journey to the tournament like you have
robbie clearly you know just i was just
ma
basically everyone was masking a bunch
by using the tournament as the thing to
focus on but then after the tournament
was done no one really felt fulfilled
it would like even though there were
some victories to be held no one really
felt uh like this was a pretty dour like
note to end on for a lot of characters
and like you know we have
of course tori who had a moment of
victory but then felt
obviously learns the truth there so
that's going to come into play later
um you know sam dealing with losing uh
robbie obviously like what have i done
to kenny look what's happened with me
you know she miguel
like i don't even want to fight him this
isn't my fight he just backs out of it
um it's it's like daniel and johnny are
both seeing like like it's well that's
why even for chris you know to have even
though he's going to jail being framed
he for crease even he himself during the
fight was like this really is about
johnny isn't it like all this is about
trying to create a different path
and uh
you know
terry realizing even that johnny's his
weakness like it's so it was so
interesting to see how they they used it
to peel back the layers of what's really
going on underneath these characters
while also giving us our candy of great
fight scenes as well so
yeah i see andrew has a monologue of
things too
to get through here so why don't we uh
just toss the ball yeah before i even do
that i mean you guys didn't mention much
she left me a lot of room to uh
elaborate more on this episode but i did
love the theme of this episode
of learning about oneself i felt like
that was kind of the theme and i mean in
particular for me it was yeah the one i
mean i gravitated towards just about all
the characters as is as you guys just
mentioned but for me it was kenny the
most um just seeing his whole journey
throughout the entire season and then
you know just seeing the pain in
robbie's eyes like on what he's
unleashed onto the sure into uh you know
the community or rather into anthony's
world i mean that was a really
interesting uh you know wave events and
i really again just a lot of times where
i think they're going to go to cliche
ways in this show they always go a more
interesting you know path than that and
i really really thought it was an
interesting choice of what they chose to
do with kenny
and yeah i'm really
you know curious and anxious to see in
the next season just how that
relationship evolves more just robbie
and kenny obviously like when robbie
gave him that dropkick he kind of just
like lost his spirit as just who he was
and just became this other monster now
and you know it's going to be
interesting to see too with kenny and
anthony's relationship because i
actually i actually really dig the
interactions with those two characters
so yeah that was a really uh he really
had an interesting character's journey
this entire season so
well i'm curious miles morales i'm
curious a little bit more about the uh
with with uh your thoughts though on on
the terry and crease
and how that went like
like i request a request elaboration
all right now elaborate on that as greg
is i mean clearly alluding to that's
definitely my favorite relationship
especially in karate kid part three and
just yeah i was not expecting that route
in any way shape or form but you know i
did find it very interesting how
terry made the point of crease is
is my you're my weakness and you know
just seeing uh the unfolding of events
there and and him getting him arrested
and playing that card with
uh st stinkray uh i just i wasn't
expecting that at all it's definitely
again another very interesting path but
it does kind of line even though you
know terry uh had that said he had that
he's sick and tired of playing the guild
card with him on him saving his life i
actually did think that was very in line
with his character just the snake that
he is in part three even though
everything was for chris just again
seeing you know no pun intended seeing
him shed the snake of the of that and i
thought that was a really interesting
choice and i'm really curious how what's
going to happen in the next season so
obviously we know chris is going to get
out of jail eventually but you know just
again i thought that was a really
elaborate and very terry silver thing to
do the only thing we didn't see terry
silver as we mentioned many times do
get the cocaine yeah
it is crazy like like terry silver
becoming the ultimate villain in that
one because
like how he started off here where he
wanderings he didn't want to be in this
at all yeah and then he gets suckered
back into it and then he starts taking
over and then he puts gets put back in
his place and you watch him deteriorate
and they don't even show you
uh like the way they they utilize the
stingray thing with without
like really cutting into it to let you
letting you know what's going on here
was brilliantly used because you're not
fully aware of it you're not like
actively thinking about it when you're
watching the show
and uh and it lines up well with him as
well because he's
you know he
he just wants to belong the stingray you
know i just want to know does stingray
go into jail too for assaulting the
neighbor
because that was not even
just i just thought about it
it is weird what is applied as a as a
law in this show that's the neighbor's
jail the neighbors like now i got i got
beat up in front of a bunch of kids i
don't care that's a really good question
yeah
he he only did a couple moves on him so
you know the penalty must be very much
lower though he just broke his phone and
beat the [ __ ] out of him in front of
kids not that big
no he's not in the hospital dying right
now
but i can't believe he would go that far
to want to be in cobra kai you know
yeah that shows the number it'll do on
you or it's fear and still but uh that's
amazing that guy's a fantastic guy it's
just so crazy how like he went to he
went from karate kid three yeah which is
terror
to go from like
so over the top like he is so over the
top of karate kid 3 and it's so fun it's
like it's a blast to watch that
and here he is so
believable like he has such a realistic
performance from beginning he goes big
at times but it's so real
and to see like wow you were like way
over the top in the third karate kid
movie and here you're uh and here they
they use a much more um
more gravitas to it so yeah what you got
there and the fact that he was retired
too and came back he comes back he's
like yeah
yeah i'm gonna reflect him in real life
you know it's like he must have learned
something let's go through the list
people
no need for fighting the mom said to
miguel miyagi said the same thing to
daniel after he injured himself in the
first film
uh we did get a lot of darth vader sith
jedi references obviously the most uh
you know the biggest thing was like uh
robbie was anakin kenny was excuse me
robbie was obi-wan kenny was anakin the
episode also was called rise we were
talking about revenge of the sith where
the emperor says rise i don't know cobra
kai
gonna die is what they said and as we
remember in cobra kai part three cobra
kai never dies
uh then we also got
miguel not gonna fight with his back
same thing as daniel with his injury and
robbie in the first season at the end we
got sudden death last time we got sudden
death as they mentioned was 1985 mike
barnes versus daniel the champ larusso
also we got
terry saying run into uh if she run it's
not her uh your fault she's running into
your elbow he said the same thing to
danny when he was trying to teach him
how to fight like cobra kai dirty saying
it's not your fault he's gonna run into
your fist or something like that but
that was a reference to that terry on
the microphone right after they win
terry was on the microphone in part
three before the mike barnes daniel
fight and then also as mentioned earlier
terry when uh getting creased to go to
jail he says we'll get a person or two
in here to me that's a mike barnes
reference possibly and i'm going to die
on this sandhill because i already died
on the terry silver as miguel's father i
think mike barnes is tory nichols father
and he lives in mexico no i said tori's
father
i'm sorry no he also lives in mexico
yeah but he also lives for different
reasons
he was so in shame after that 1985 fight
she's a bum on the street
um you know that's a good point good
calls man
thank you greg for the notebook of
course of course um
i mean one thing that we haven't touched
on i think it's because it was so such a
highlight for me and like uh acts of
love can really move me to tears so much
and
uh
one thing that we haven't touched on was
the thing with robbie and johnny
i would uh knows i mean yeah we can we
can go to that
we could elaborate more on that it was
more about the
johnny and
daniel oh yeah yeah
coming to coming together
and uh how that also affected the
relationship with
sam and john thoughts oh yeah i i've
been enjoying maybe you know in the
earlier parts of that arc you know there
were some moments that maybe felt a
little bumpy but i really liked how they
realized it here and based off the last
episode where johnny has that outburst
when sam gets the point you know uh i
thought they did nicely to bring those
themes together and i thought it was a
really cathartic scene where johnny and
danny actually talk and actually admit
to one another that yeah maybe
you know our feud us being stuck in our
ways is you know affecting our kids
abilities to succeed here and maybe yeah
if we could
you know it almost feels like just a
more enlightened place uh a more
enlightened version of where we left
them last time around of like okay we've
seen you know the sort of the first
formation of how we work together we
realize what pitfalls we can fall into
now you know we've seen it in action
through our proteges
maybe we can rebuild this stronger and
faster i like that that doesn't like
perfectly work right up top but it does
at least give sam some of that extra
juice she needs to go and fight her own
style and both of them being wise enough
to let go and say yes go pursue your own
style and i liked how that mirrored what
robbie's dealing with too you know like
that philosophy that he's already
arrived at through different means
uh and yeah to have the two championship
fights kind of come down to that you
know i thought was really nice well i
think uh
she would have won
yeah like she did she hit tory
before tori was out of bounds and then
she got elbowed in the eye you know um
and i do believe tory on that that was
an accident but i think what they did so
beautifully there was
bringing it because i think a lot of the
time when people you know like there's a
old quote i heard which was to be
successful study success
and i think what sometimes people get a
little bit lost in and i think what this
season really dealt with especially with
flashing back to karate kid 3 with
miyagi
is that yeah you have to study you have
to study and learn it and learn it but
at the end of the day
you have to make it your own
if you just try to copy there's only so
far you can go
and you know it's like how can you
really trust your instincts when you're
just coming so much from here trying to
mirror mimic and then you know that's
what i thought was so beautiful about
like like when they said like i love
when they came together and were like
apologetic and stuff and then you know
even like daniel making sure johnny gets
the credit he deserves with saying
two-time valley champion like really
showing the respect but
with uh sam you know like that [ __ ]
move me when he when he was like what
style do i mess [ __ ] break me right
now when he says what style do you use
and then uh he says uh your style i was
like oh that is so good i didn't even
expect that answer
like it just it was just so perfect
and
um yeah like allowing the freedom for
that because it was just so it was there
this uh so many of the because robbie in
a lot of ways as angry as he was he was
also right about so many things
of everyone thinks their ways the right
way and and i think what this show i
think we said this about like every
[ __ ] season what this show does
remarkably well
is
exploring the gray on everything and i
think that's so important for something
like this and i think that's what keeps
this show alive
is the fact that they don't go black and
white with any situation they they
always find a way to
um
explore more of the complexity behind
something
while giving us like a great 80s
lively vibe throughout it's so
impressive how they do it but you want
to know to talk a little bit more about
uh robbie and johnny uh sure yeah no i
really just seeing how tumultuous that
relationship has been since the very
first episode we've had plenty of time i
mean obviously we had the they had their
one uh relieving moment in terms of
uh where they started treating each
other like father and son and uh towards
the end of season two and then obviously
robbie kicked miguel off the balcony and
it you know went back to the tumultuous
uh relationship again but i was really
again just when you talk about how much
this show moves you there was just so
many different moving parts but i mean
that when they hugged each other and
he's crying he calls him dad i mean that
was god really hit the field yeah i know
i was thinking i kind of said out loud
in that moment like i hope miguel
doesn't see this that would really looks
like after what just happened in that
episode eight at the end where you know
he called him robbie and you know
because that's really what i mean
obviously miguel is a very you know big
big deal to johnny that's like his son
as well but you know just seeing that
moment for them having their father-son
moment was just really well earned to me
it wasn't forced in any way and i mean
those two actors have just such great
chemistry and i really like is tanner
buchanan is that his name yeah
he's fantastic he's really grown on me
as a character i think it was the hair
in the first two seasons possibly for me
but he's really grown a lot i mean the
reality is his acting is also
greatly improved yeah yeah
much better guys yeah one final question
i really want to know is michael really
going to mexico to find his error is he
going to go train with the league of
shadows meet bruce yeah get set up
batman begins just saying well i think
it's interesting what they did with
miguel this season because miguel is um
i didn't really feel like he was one of
the strongest like had the strongest
presence this time around yet i think
that actually works so well because of
the ending
of
no one really suspects just how much is
going on with this guy of how much he's
dealing with and that's a very realistic
thing is you know like i didn't even
realize he's not really talking about
things and
a lot of times when he has opportunities
to talk about things he doesn't really
take the opportunity he might like have
a little bit of an explosion or he
contains and becomes like you know he
just he's always trying to be
understanding or trying to see things a
different way
and and and cooperate and move things
along and it would he but there's so
much internal lies that he was dealing
with i'm like oh that's actually kind of
powerful i think because
to me it's easy to look at it and go
ahead miguel i didn't really feel like
because there's so many other things
that obviously we're all talking about
first i mean we brought up miguel's
ending moment first but i think in a lot
of this this season in particular you
know you're
like tori and her her arc and like
seeing how tori really cares i think is
like i really like the way that last
fight was done you know of how her her
concern wasn't even about winning
her concern really was about you know
like are you okay sam and i think sam
was even like
is this a trick you know are you trying
to manipulate me like what's going on
here
um like the fear is still there and so
much and so i love that but like what
they did with miguel i think is also of
great effect here
yeah it's crazy there's there's some
great
i think a lot of times season finales
shows i'm like okay here we are just a
whole bunch of setups and it's rare
where you have season finale setting up
the next season where those setups are
so [ __ ] emotional
you know and i'm like you don't really
get well do you guys you guys kind of
get what i mean by that usually it is
just like we're setting this up here
we're setting this up get ready
yeah and here i'm just like oh this is
like emotional [ __ ] who are there people
gonna be in whatever time passage that
is when we pick up in season five
and i think like the way they handled
like tori and amanda uh too as well i i
thought was what i thought was cool was
smart to do was like amanda has her
speech to tori about making sure to play
fair
and i thought it was great that they had
you know because my my concern was oh is
sam gonna play dirty now and like oh
crap it's gonna get flipped but to have
her be you know come make amends with
her dad
beforehand so you know they're both
gonna play fair just give me cause they
gave us two very different fights
like with hawk
with eli and robbie
which was
how do i describe this that eli and
robbie were a lot more like
it was like a bigger action movie yeah
you know
there's a lot more kicks and flips and
then they're moving around the mat like
a whole lot more where as uh
where whereas like i would describe more
man i'm i'm so teared out uh
i would describe more
of tori and sam as much more like
using their upper body and hands and
there's more form in that in that regard
you know more of that technique whereas
like robbie and
eli were a little bit more dirty and a
little more of a bro big yeah i was more
expressive in the way of how they use it
so i thought it was cool that they also
gave us two very different types of
choreography what like like satori and
sam are a lot more in here and then
robbie and eli are
like they're just moving around all over
the place you know uh that that was
really cool that was that's really
impressive good for rely man so what
you're saying is the fight between eli
and robbie was endgame and the fight
between sam and tory was no way home
like yes
there's a one-to-one comparison yeah i
think so
okay something along those lines is
there anything we missed
chosen's coming oh you chose it
you keep this for your collection yeah
that's cool that's cool how they brought
that back
now we just need hillary swank we need
mike barnes yeah
jaden smith in a multiverse we need to
find a secret hidden fifth karate kid
movie to mind more characters
i guess like what struck me as like so
dark and impactful was how
the consequences of the choices of this
path of everyone you know like
chris brings
terry
look when he's out in jail
uh the kids are off way worse than they
were but like every one of them is
pretty most of them are you know
i don't think i want to say all of them
but
most of them are off worse than they
were the only person i think who walks
out of this episode with a relatively
uplifting note is is eli
and he started off on a you know really
downward yeah whereas i
kind of on the daniel note though i
don't oh guys it's really the right
maneuver yeah it's the right mover
[ __ ] yeah you know
show life
no he should honor the deal and stop
teaching karate so what is the deal here
that he's uh he said he's going to keep
teaching karate right yeah he said he's
not going to do a deal with the snakes
or something like it's something like
that he's not going to honor that deal
guys who have no honor yeah honor a deal
with guys who have no longer
but does he they don't no one knows that
he bought the match off
no but we know that's obviously it's
gonna come out i mean tory knows the
truth
how stupid of them why would you meet
like talk about that right at the match
like meet somewhere else it's a movie
show cliche
that was cliched i mean i was expecting
her to go in and have some kind of thing
with sam that's what i said moment i was
happy for the misdirect yeah and yeah i
mean it is a nice for the progression of
her and robbie's relationship too of
them
sort of finding their own uh
approach and thought process outside of
the crease terry mind wash bubble you
know i i could see that being a nice
driver for her in season five to be like
okay maybe i'll uh break off of cobra
kai and consider something else
yeah i love this this was awesome this
was uh this is seriously awesome this
was a great season she's gonna join me
aggie fang
yeah
i think the way they built this up was
it was excellent they that the way they
got here is has they juggled so much
yeah it's a lot to juggle and i thought
they did it just like wonderfully the
mcu is good at handling a multitude here
okay see you the kccu
ckcu now
i'm glad you this is still late tonight
that we're filming this guys i'm glad
you're with us on this journey thank you
for having me appreciate it this is it's
amazing to have you here karate kid
reaction next week creative part two
week after that part three then we'll
get next karate kid i've never seen the
next karate kid
have you
unfortunately a few times is it actually
like not even enjoyably bad
that's
there's some good moments i mean you
still get miyagi uh but overall it's
not the greatest film um but
would you be excited if they announced
hillary's swing yeah i would be i i i
mean i wasn't crazy about the character
but it would be cool to see a legacy
character i guess so uh i mean i i think
i mean she's a great actress i mean you
see her million dollar baby come on boys
don't boys don't cry or
right she's a good actor boys in the
hood is weird yeah definitely boys
but no if they really did announce our
character coming back i i would i would
be okay with that i mean she did learn a
lot of lessons from mr miyagi too so i
mean to see them instill that chosen
definitely be
a multitude of different uh voices but i
i'd be cool with that if they end up
coming back with hillary swank i fully
expect them to come back with sean kane
and mike barnes at some point if not
next season i'd be kind of shocked
i feel like they set up so much and i'm
like i don't need to wrap this up in the
next season
they're like we're running out of movies
we've got to set out enough stakes that
we have at least two or three more
seasons
they set up so much that i'm like wow
you can't how would you finish that in
10 more episodes
that is so much to deal with right there
you can already see the first episode
johnny in mexico just struggling to
understand anyone yeah
that's right you got one kid [ __ ]
mexico you gotta go all the way there
hey but maybe he'll pick up some crazy
you know mexican martial art that'd be
cool bring it back
use it like what i have no idea what
kind of fighting style
let us know in the comment section what
kind of fighting styles but i'm sure
every country has a proprietary means of
fighting
all right guys well thank you so much
for being here hey let's do a page
john can you shout out uh brian perry
brian perry brian my friend if there's
anybody at our patreon who i know would
not be afraid to strike first and strike
hard it's definitely you because i know
you that well you've got aggression
problems brian perry i think you should
learn from robbie's journey here and
maybe let your guard down a little brian
let us know what's going on behind those
million miles staring eyes of yours all
right you're kind enough to be here with
us every month on patreon which means a
lot and we're not going to betray you we
are a support system and we are always
on d
fence not anything else that begins with
the d unless that's your thing which hey
cool but brian for right now i just want
to say much love to you thank you for
your generosity and showing us the mercy
of your patronage and support hope
you're doing well hope 2022 is off to a
good start for you you are the champion
in our hearts bryan perry catch you next
time
you rock right
[Music]